this is a production of cornell
university
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the long island horticultural research
and extension center is a 68-acre
cornell university facility on the
eastern end of the island the mission of
our research center is to help our
agricultural community out here in
suffolk county succeed
the main focus is applied research and
education and i think that is something
that really the growers can't get
elsewhere we focus on long island soils
and microclimates and being you know in
this maritime climate we are pretty
unique compared to the rest of the state
and that that's important to have that
research and education that is directly
applicable to our area we are an
extension of cornell university we are
providing you with the information
that's done at cornell university and
also
the very applicable research that's done
here at the research lab and we're
extending that out into the community
i think it's important to have this
resource for growers and landscape
professionals for a number of reasons
probably the most important is that
there are day-to-day problems and issues
that need to be solved
that
can put them out of business
if a grower is not sustainable they're
not going to stay in production so
sustainable and how they're growing
things sustainable in their business
all very important so i'm looking at
managing plant diseases in the best
possible way the most effective way so
they're going to have minimal
cost going into control because they're
using the best possible practices
implementing sustainable practices all
farmers want to increase the
sustainability of their operation all
farmers are looking to improve soil
health and have a better crop at the end
of the day farms are businesses
and sustainability and longevity is
extremely important
we've changed over time
from a
philosophy of using a chemical to stop a
problem to using more of a strategy to
stop a problem
we have a program with orchards where
we've introduced
mating disruption for example so that
can substitute for the use of pesticides
it also can give you better control
than you would have with insecticides so
that's widely been adopted here it's
very successful it works quite well
inside this tube there is the same
chemicals what a female insects actually
release this pheromone mating disruption
technology is a non-insecticidal
control method and it is organically
compatible
so this is a good for environment so you
don't have to use any insecticides when
you are using the insect mating
disruption ties
[Music]
it's important to me that growers
understand when it's too late to make a
pesticide application or when it's
important
to do something at a certain time in
relation to the crop production cycle
because then they're not wasting
chemicals that could otherwise just not
be put into the environment
if they're doing the right thing at the
right time then they achieve their
objective and they're not polluting
soil health is is critical soil is a
living system and how we manage it has a
direct impact not just on farms and in
the crops being grown but
environmentally downstream and with the
agricultural stewardship program we're
focusing on protecting our ground and
surface waters here on long island
we're trying to maintain the aquifer
which is the sole source of our drinking
water as pure as it can be we need to
figure out a way to manage the weeds
even without some of the tools that
other people have
when not only you see your research and
are able to show growers the research is
successful but they adopt it that's when
you know you've you've really made a
difference
[Music]
having a place where we have specialists
from entomologists to plant pathologists
to soil scientists and floriculturalists
is so critical agriculture is a system
and we all need to collaborate and work
together to be the best resource for our
farmers
[Music]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu